time now for pft on yahoo sports he's
peter king i'm mike floria taking a look
at some of the biggest stories in the
national football league and one of the
biggest stories the first several weeks
of the season what the heck is wrong
with the patriots now after barely
beating the jets in prime time on a
monday and then handling the ravens on a
sunday in prime time patriots have won
two in a row they're four and five peter
are they still alive in the afc
i think they're alive mike uh and i
think who knows they might be the
seventh seed in the playoffs you never
know
um but i i also think that this
shouldn't
blind anyone to the reality of what the
patriots really are right now and that
is a team that needs to rebuild they've
got to figure out their long-term
quarterback which
i doubt they have on their roster but
hey you never know maybe they resigned
cam newton for a couple of years and and
see what happens
um but you know you you don't know who
the quarterback's gonna be
you know other than the ascending jacoby
myers you really don't know a lot about
what
your uh your skill positions are going
to be
so there's a lot of work to be done with
this team but hey
i i named josh mcdaniels one of my
coaches of the week this week and i
think
what he has done
with lesser talent to put it mildly at
all of his skill positions and figuring
out hey jacoby myers you can actually
throw the football so the biggest play
in the game against the ravens what is
it it's an option pass from jacoby myers
to rex burkhead
and you know nobody's ever seen jacoby
myers throw the ball so
that is what you do
when you are talent disadvantaged and i
think the patriots especially mcdaniels
has done a good job with that
they're currently the 10th seed in the
afc so they would have to leapfrog three
teams down the stretch which means they
need to win as many games as they can if
they would run the table and finish 11
and 5 i suspect they would not get
nudged out like in 2008 when they went
11-5 and didn't make it because of that
seventh spot
but peter
as a practical matter they've got a lot
of work to do this hole that they've dug
themselves is not going to be easy to
climb out of and they've got some
challenging games coming they've got
some very winnable games but they still
have the cardinals they still have the
rams they still have the dolphins they
still have the bills
mike
listen we shan't get too excited about a
team that's won two in a row
one of them a week ago in which they
were behind the worst team
in recent nfl history
by ten points in the fourth quarter
and in the other one
i don't know how much of an advantage
playing in a monsoon is
and i don't know why it would be a
bigger big advantage for new england
other than so many of their players have
played in lousy a lot of lousy weather
but
i mean let's be a little bit realistic
the new england patriots are four and
five they're not very good we'll see
what happens
and other than that i can't get too
excited about them and i also can't
believe that if they did make the
playoffs as the sixth or seventh seed
uh that they'd make a lot of damage
unless look
if they go on a ridiculous run and
finish 11-5
then talk to me then but this just
doesn't look like that team that could
go on an 11 uh you know it could finish
11-5
i will say this
the terminator is not dead until you
have melted him down
and turned him into a line of
wristwatches
and i'm not going to assume that this
patriots team can't figure out where
it's going it's what john harbaugh told
me last week getting ready to face the
patriots they're still the patriots they
still have bill belichick and look they
they still got bit by the patriots even
though they went in there on guard of
what they could be walking into and
peter if i'm the chiefs or the steelers
and i'm hosting a divisional round game
i'd much rather have the browns or the
raiders than the new england patriots
rolling into town in a single
elimination setting
give me
a team where they're going to be
wide-eyed and it's new to them
not a team that has a coach who has been
there and done that over and over and
over again with the season riding on the
outcome of one game
maybe
i mean i think
far too excited about the new england
patriots after they came back to beat
the new york jets
down by 10. it's just let's let's settle
down a bit
oh come on let's have some fun we'll
have some fun again with another edition
of pft on yahoo sports have a great day
we'll see you next time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports